the virus is really hitting all of China
at once the forecast for deaths in China
reaches high as over 2 million
[Music]
China's road to reopening is a little
bit like that Ernest Hemingway phrase
gradually and then suddenly the pressure
has really been building for a year now
since the arrival of Omicron because
that Varian is just so transmissible
that China's classic Playbook of
lockdowns mass testing was becoming less
and less effective against stopping
spread
then there were these unprecedented
protests that happened at the end of
November people taking to the streets
some even calling for presidency to step
down since then China has basically let
it rip all of these measures now have
been overturned the only thing that
remains for China is these travel curves
that we expect to be eased quite soon as
well what we're seeing right now is that
really initial stage of infection that
we saw in so many other countries in
early 2020 where you know suddenly over
a couple of days almost everybody you
know is infected what's really worrisome
coming after this stage is when serious
illness and fatalities will set in
there's a lot of concern over how the
elderly especially are under vaccinated
and they're vaccinated with Chinese
vaccines which we know are not as
effective as the Western mrnas the
health system is under strain you know
officials are telling people please
don't come to the hospitals unless
you're seriously sick they're trying to
prioritize the most vulnerable the virus
is really hitting all of China at once I
think we can see the same thing really
happen in all major cities over the next
six to eight eight weeks we start to see
fatalities in around four to six weeks
and then the infection Curve will start
to come down but you know as we've seen
in so many other countries around the
world the waves keep coming back there
may be another variant which is a really
big unknown that experts are quite
concerned about because you're talking
about 1.4 billion people the more people
get the virus the more it evolves
[Music]